we did end up having to reproject and
sort of redo the Chopsticks in CG as
well
the idea what this scene was we were
going to go like okay now we're gonna do
what lasers really do she has the
lightning and her hand is being lit up
by that purple lightning yeah what's the
process on lighting here
big thanks to Puget systems for
sponsoring today's episode
hey welcome back to another episode of
visual effects artists react we are
honored to be joining the couch once
again by Stefan Fleet the visual effects
supervisor of the boys lots of you have
probably seen it is in my opinion the
best show currently is Aaron there's a
lot of blood and gore and Fun Stuff
disturbing stuff yeah I have a feeling
this episode is gonna be another bloody
episode to me I equate this right now to
like a game of operation where I have to
like not get you guys demonetized be
very careful with what I can and can't
talk about but um but there's some
interesting stuff we had a really fun
time doing season three and you know
some of the craziest most unprecedented
stuff I've ever been involved with in my
life and some stuff I can say that I
don't think has ever been done before
for television which is pretty pretty
darn cool so I think I should state
right off the bat if you've watched the
first episode of the boys we're not
going to look at that scene scene we
can't
you know what I'm talking about what do
you want to start with let's start with
the opening guys we call it the dog dawn
of the seventh oh yeah that's right yeah
this is our movie within the show dawn
of the seven and it's supposed to be
like our homage to Mr Zack Snyder who
actually saw and had some pleasant
comments to say about it online or
something to me
they built a pretty great set like that
bus and all that rubble and a lot of the
fire is real we added the heat waves
Distortion a lot of smoke more fire but
the most interesting thing about this
scene is it was shot not only in two
different places but at two different
times in Toronto and Los Angeles wait
what yeah those are two different
locations I know I know so essentially
and while we filmed the Toronto side
first I went and I did a complete scan
actually honestly with polycam oh yeah
my phone really yeah polycam is my
friend man I go around everything and
just get like a polycam backup or
whatever so I did a polycam scan and I
created a whole like time of day sun
mapped I created this whole packet for
the LA unit I had to stay in Toronto so
we hired another soup to to cover it
another soup
another VFX supervisor
and yeah and then they they hired a unit
here and they recreated some like the
fire truck with you see like a parachute
on it and stuff like that so they
recreated have to set here in LA and
shot it much later so what you're seeing
is you know visual effects putting two
things together
and then we did some Powers here and we
actually went a little cheesy and over
the top with the powers usually we strip
stuff back and kind of go more raw but
you know I had a question about a
specific shot in that opening sequence
sure it was when Stormfront ish
storefront Charlie's front yes storm
fake uh she has the lightning and her
hand is being lit up by that purple
lightning a lot of the times for
something like that I would just do that
in 2D what's the process on lighting her
hand I'm a big fan of practical lighting
however in this instance if you're
shooting broad daylight exterior you're
not going to get much out of throwing
some LEDs on someone's hands and it's
going to slow down production and you're
always thinking about speed and time and
stuff if it's a dark room I would say
you need light because that light's
going to light up the room you know
you're going to need some kind of
reactive light but again daylight
exterior also she has black gloves on
they're they're more forgiving to light
up so in this case we scanned the
actress they match moved her hand and
then yeah all that reactive lighting was
cast in MCG you actually recreate a 3D
model of her hand and then you're
actually lighting that in 3D space yeah
so like instead of doing like a shadow
catcher which you're talking about
before yeah it's basically just yeah and
it works a lot of the time it's
definitely easier on production and the
truth is if we can get away with a 2d or
a two and a half day solution we will on
a shot like this there's actually a
significant amount of Parallax the
camera's panning and moving so you do
have some 3D depth there if I don't have
to I don't main handle a shot like this
this particular company is a company
called Rising Sun pictures in Australia
and you know the artist was the one that
was creative and found a way to cast
that light on her hand that just looked
great and I didn't have to say much to
be honest because I got the shot like
this looks amazing you get the shot your
Note is like dope so if you think about
it like it's just so crazy in this
industry that you have like so many
people contributing their creative and
Technical talents to something like this
that you know is truly an international
production in that one shot you've got
Toronto LA and Australia all coming
together I mean I just think it's great
that's super cool yeah
oh yeah this is the first big bloody
explosion of the episode yeah this was
probably one of the hardest most
challenging bits to do
oh I've somehow already forgotten that
like his head doesn't blow up all at
once did the pool of blood in the back
of his throat where you can see him
breathing that was one of the hardest
shots because you're going into uncanny
valley territory where you're staring at
a human head all right that length with
really no way out the scene though was
really hard it took a long time it took
months to accomplish there's definitely
some real but a lot of CG going on so
what do you have going on there so you
have the actor you probably have
Prosthetics and these are like just a
big did you just yeah it's a green it's
like kind of like the flaps down here
are real and then the eye had a little
bit of green we did a lot of work on the
eye area I think and then obviously
anything like the jawline inside the
mouth of the CG I mean the whole point
of the storytelling in this sequence is
to see this guy gruesomely in pieces
blow up we had some great assistance
Zayn is our practical Prosthetics guy on
the show and he created this like fake
half blown off hand we kept the real
hand sometimes but we ended up actually
replacing the hand in CG are you guys
sticklers about Anatomy like do you like
go like all right well we actually have
a skull and me neat and you know yeah I
mean where do we like to use is grounded
we like to say we're a very grounded
show and we try and commit everything
from a point of realism and then at a
certain point you take it to this
fantastic level it really depends from
shot to shot so this like we're going
big on this one like we wanted to gross
people out and we wanted to you know
make it painful and excruciating and
long and that's intentional so I think
you get to that point where you're like
oh if we cheat this little piece here or
you know maybe it wouldn't exactly be
this but if we do this here it's better
for the shot the key thing again for us
is like we never want people to stop and
think about the visual effect we always
want people to just be into the moment
in the story at least the first time but
wait a minute this shot isn't over yet
though this this shot though is about to
get
bigger
now I would call that like I mean it's
again it's really hard work and we spend
a lot of time on it I've done a body
explosion or two in my time now on the
boys
you know uh it's your it's your
traditional boys good old body explosion
what's great is we have this special
effects team the Kenny family up in
Toronto they've been with us in season
one and they'll always come out and I
always have them do a practical
explosion I think we talked about last
season called blood lollipops whatever
but don't always come out with some kind
of blood bag and blow something up it's
always great to have that reference of
like blood and also like hitting people
with it and some of the Mist coming over
like Huey here that's real and then we
extended it and we did it in visual
effects over her to like keep the moment
going what's the secret to making good
looking guts like there's chunkiness to
it but like you also got to get the
glossiness right being season three we
actually weirdly like just have our own
language on the show and these guys at
rocket science they did the head wedding
as it's called last season so we've just
we have this shorthand of like we like
our blood ropey you know we like our
colons you know this shape inside
so it's always a balance between like
how much Mist versus like ropey blood
versus chunky stuff we tend to do less
Mist if you'll notice in our stuff Mist
usually comes from the Practical
elements because when you do practical
explosions like squibs and stuff like
that there's like a CO2 component that
shoots out of mist so when we're doing
the visual effects out of it we actually
try and like pull back on the Mist
knowing that that'll either be there
from the Practical or it just shouldn't
be there at all so that's so funny
because when we are doing blood effects
we usually are adding that mist element
ourselves yeah I mean and again like
every show I've done is different for
whatever reason on this show the
language we've built over the years is
more of again like I would call it a
ropey style of blood where you see these
sort of strands shooting up they'll then
disintegrate into raindrops at a certain
point and some chunks you know I find
the color of blood to be one of the
hardest things to get right both in
terms of making your fake blood and when
you have to like do digital blood yeah
oh yeah because like looking at this
shot you see like the blood in a lot of
cases is black yeah yeah we go for a
darker more maroon you know Mystic
pumpkin
no no it's like but we we definitely
have our tone of blood I actually that's
a note I give a lot a lot of times I'll
get the blood stuff in for the first
couple rounds and it'll be more bright
red which weirdly is actually more
accurate to what real you know blood
looks like it's pretty candy apple real
blood but just like we have a heavy
color grade on the show that gives it a
lot of contrast and darkness I think we
have to lend ourselves to that so yeah
so we go very dark even though it's not
real it adds the level of filmic realism
to it to me I mean it's also like that's
where reference becomes really important
because seeing what happens to your
stage blood once you run it through the
color grade and everything yeah it's
like okay you have to match those colors
with all this arbitrary colors that
you're just making up later on sure it's
not like there's a hex value for blood
no
I have seen a lot of reference on this
show guys let me tell you like places
that you don't want to go in life
but yeah this was I would say this
episode has some of our biggest and most
unprecedented visual effects we've ever
done for the show hey you know what I
think now is a really good time for you
to hit this button
it's down there over the Subscribe
button you know down there yes
that way
you know if you want to like see what
we're up to cool video coming out
tomorrow just saying subscribe
chefs specialty
it is a South Korean delicacy oh it's
Timothy Timothy the octopus this scene
kind of broke me it was hard to watch
[Music]
I'm so sorry
dude I'm noticing like like the
tentacles are literally pulling on his
face yeah collaboration again with our
uh practical effects team and a little
bit
um there's a combination of things going
on and even a little bit of puppeteering
so we had a full rubber Timothy and we
used him as reference so when you cut to
the plate we did a reference pass of him
but then we pulled him into the clean
plates of a plate clean plate
thank you folks I think is this the
first is that the first Clean Plate on
film I don't know
so it starts with like we had the rubber
thing then like what's he gonna put in
his mouth so we ended up creating like a
head like a rubber headed computer but
then when he's sucking them up what's he
gonna do to suck them up so our props
team took over at that point that a food
specialist create a vegan tentacle looks
like a gummy worm kind of that he could
suck up it's the right size not the
right texture we had to skin over it but
it gave him again something tangible
because you want those Chopsticks to
grab onto something you can't air ball
that stuff it's gonna look like a
nightmare and also I assume something to
inflate his cheeks from the insides yeah
so he's inflating his cheeks with the
real stuff like the stuff is filling his
mouth that's a good point and then again
we had two pieces of string with with
tape on his cheeks like pulling I
noticed that immediately like the
tentacles like one on each side of his
face and his point you can actually see
like little wrinkles for forming from
skin being pulled like under his eye
like way far away from the effect again
I was like I knew this was going to be a
tough one I mean I was like this is not
easy this is not easy work so we need to
get as much real stuff as we can into
the arena here and then also there's
this ink that comes out of his mouth and
that's a lot of real ink too they create
in the in the uh the head piece they
created like an ink balloon and chase by
the way did a lot of tests and
rehearsals with it so the fact that you
didn't actually kill a real octopus yeah
Peta themselves were like get on you
here's an award and it's kind of cool
man like the fact of the matter is we
never intended to use a real octopus in
this sequence from the beginning one
because it's really complicated but two
like we would never want to you know do
that to an octopus hey have you seen old
boy I've seen Noble oh I believe me I
watched old boy a lot in referencing
this scene and uh that was you know
that's a film from another time you just
can't do something like that in this day
and age especially for American
television just it's just a No-No and
then you know one of the hardest things
was getting the interaction of the
Chopsticks connected to the actual
octopus because when he was grabbing
thing it was shaking a little bit more
than we wanted so we did end up having
to reproject and sort of redo the
Chopsticks in CG as well you just
casually say that oh yeah we had to like
redo the channel it was quite difficult
yeah so you painted out the Chopsticks
in the shot and now you have CG
Chopsticks like something you could do
in a situation like this if you had to
is since you have the real Chopsticks
there and you're always going to be at
this angle you could take a frame of the
real Chopsticks create a CG model of
Chopsticks reanimate the movement and
then reproject that frame back onto it
kind of like camera mapping right uh
yeah camera projection and it'll have a
real texture to it they're shiny so you
have to deal with lighting and movement
and all that stuff but yeah that would
be the challenge is that like when you
start projection mapping something back
on all of the highlights and lighting is
baked in yeah so we had to obviously
handle that and put it like a chrome
like texture on it so this was an
incredibly challenging shot I would say
that the biggest thing is from the
get-go the performance is really big you
tend to go cartoony with the character
like you give them a personality
Timothy's like well you know and Eric
was the one that kept saying like peel
it back peel it back what would a real
octopus do like even when we opened the
tray I think our original shot had the
head like sort of popping up and
flapping down and Eric they killed that
and it was such a smart thing to do
because really in this instance I think
everyone knows that it's not real
um just because of the nature of the
scene you want it to look as real as
possible in visual effects and you do
want to give it a performance but you
still kind of want to find that pocket
of like real octopus but with horror in
its eyes right yeah I mean I feel like
the thing that makes all of this work is
the fact that little Timothy is like so
cute
the eyes I'm like I actually see like a
soul behind those eyes and it hurts to
see that
I'm good then we achieved our goal I was
watching this and like the emotions are
real I had to like pause and reflect on
the fact that I'm watching a goofy
superhero show and it's hitting like
this is a real intense drama it's a dude
eating an octopus while it talks to him
it's it's Aquaman are you having to eat
a fish and he shared his tuna fish
sandwich with me
it's so funny but at the same time it's
so serious it hits and it lands it's
like that's hard to do but yeah I don't
know man it was um I'm very very proud
of this sequence as horrific as it is I
mean it's very well done yeah yeah it's
great it's a really good scene
you're my hero growing up this is kind
of cool man so we finally did like a
really big superhero fight soup V soup V
soup I'm the upgrade
all right
a lot of wall hits oh yeah but it's
about to get it's about to get big
boy boy
homelander has never been like injured
in his life
and he's using his own tricks against
him laser eyes versus laser
laser oh there it is that's the shot
that's the Colbert thing that he used to
make they were making fun of the other
guy yeah this was a very well received
scene and it's exciting to me because we
worked really hard on it the very first
shot you see back at the beginning of
this the actual shot where he flies and
slams soldier boy up against the wall
right there that's a full digital double
of homelander oh really yeah and then it
cuts into a real shot and it's a pretty
clever wire thing yeah I was about to
say I remember seeing an image of the
behind the scenes of this moment there's
a lot of wires holding them up yeah yeah
so that's that close up when they Smash
in John kuyama props to him and he
really mapped out the entire sequence
and he made wire pulls not feel like
wire pulls he was really good at
communicating to me what he needed to do
for wires and pads and stuff so I was
prepared ahead of time it was some of
the most sophisticated wire work I've
seen in my career and also some of the
most unobtrusive like I don't know how
he did it a lot of times you come in as
a visual effects to a scene like this
and it's like you're shooting through
spaghetti there's just like wires and
you're like oh boy but we have to add
the cape on anytime there's wires
because obviously the wires would
conflict with the cape you know I was
actually gonna ask about the cake
because it's like I saw him like go down
like oh that that's a real looking Cape
nice I I bet because of you know this is
a show you got a whole lot of stuff you
got to do the Cape is probably mostly
real and then you turn around like well
actually anytime there's wire work
cape's not real and it's like yeah that
makes total sense it ends up being CG a
fair amount of times anytime he's doing
anything crazy again like wires or
flying or anything like that we're gonna
pull the cape and go CG because like you
also kind of want to like be able to
control the physics of it when he's
flying because that's a big tell for
which way the wind's moving by the way
speaking of of wires you may have
noticed that we're not in our usual spot
the first time in three years of doing
this show we have not shot down there
and that's because
show that's going on the Netflix YouTube
Channel still
put a lot of love and effort into it
we're really proud of it and the show
premieres next weekend we've been
documenting the entire shooting editing
and VFX process for each episode and you
can check all of that out on the crew
cuts on our website follow along on our
website quarterdigital.com there's a
funny story with the the Dual lasering
if you go back to that first scene we
looked at with the dawn of the seven
this act Snyder thing this was a
symmetry thing when they're all blasting
each other and the whole point is Zack
Snyder thing was we were like we're
gonna do that thing that they do in
Harry Potter where the two lasers hit
each other and you know it's just like
we're kind of making fun of it to be
perfectly honest and then the idea with
this scene was we were going to go like
okay now we're going to do what lasers
would really do when they laser each
other so I did a lot of research and
what you learned is the lasers would go
right through each other yeah
yeah it's white yeah it's light so they
would not Smash in the middle and so we
tried that and it looked like [ __ ]
so very quickly we were like all right
we're just gonna do the thing we're the
two lasers to meet in the middle and
it's going to be rad and uh and it was
and um you know like all things on our
show I think our first version was
probably bigger and we toned it down and
pulled it back because you know we want
to find that balance for our show so now
I understand why people do this and when
they have their laser AP laser battles
yes yes more more more
one more
that's enough you see editing this
reaction takes a lot of time and effort
and processing power we can only do it
on a powerful computer and that's why I
want to tell you about the computers we
use from Puget systems so what is a
Puget well it's a computer that's been
specifically designed and tailored to
meet your needs they have a group of
professionals that are on standby to
find out what you need in a computer and
they will rigorously test their machines
to make sure that it will not fail on
you
think about it computer is the most
important tool an artist uses and you
want to make sure that that tool is
reliable you don't want this computer
breaking on you and with the Puget
systems PC you can rest easy knowing
that this thing will not break on you
and on the off chance that something
does happen maybe you messed it up
somehow their customer support team will
not even hesitate to try to help you all
the way through it like legit though
their customer support team is great I
have had a problem before it was my
fault but they didn't hesitate to help
me through the entire process at this
point all of us here at Corridor use
Puget computers it's really allowed us
to level up our VFX workflow here as you
can see Fenner here is working across
two computers rendering out hundreds of
VFX shots for sun of the dungeon season
two these things are great and reliable
and if you're interested in having that
same level of rigorous testing and
reliability check the link down in the
description or go to pugersystems.com
Tom Porter sent you they'll love to hear
it in the meantime uh yeah thanks for
watching look at Nico star white star
white star white star white all right
we're talking about the boys obviously
and so Gore plays heavily into that what
are some your favorite Gore visual
effects from horror movies regular
movies doesn't matter I want to see some
disturbing stuff visual effects not
special effects not practical visual
digital alright please leave a comment
below for any suggestions so we can pull
them up in a future episode of the show
Stefan thank you so much for joining us
it's been an absolute pleasure the show
is amazing thank you for putting so much
Blood Sweat and Tears both digital and
practical into this amazing piece of
entertainment I can't wait to see more
of it for all of you out there you
should go follow Stefan on his Twitter
and his Instagram and you know if you
send him a message he told me he'll
personally respond to every single one
I'm so sorry boy maybe but I didn't say
win though it could be like August 2027
but I'll do my best so thank you guys
it's been it's always great coming here
you guys are awesome oh yeah I really
appreciate it and I hope you enjoy your
next nine months in Toronto thank you
yeah winter
[Laughter]